las filas siguen creciendo en los
centros de pruebas de kobe 19 en
shanghai ya que la ciudad informó de más
de 20.000 nuevos casos el miércoles un
récord desde el inicio de la pandemia un
revés para la estrategia china de cero
cobit sin embargo las autoridades
parecen no tener intención de renunciar
a ella todavía la tarea más urgente para
nosotros es intensificar las medidas de
transporte y aislamiento una vez que se
detecten nuevos casos positivos deben
ser trasladados a los hospitales
designados para su aislamiento inmediato
y recibir el tratamiento oportuno sin
demora
los habitantes de la mayor ciudad del
país se han visto obligados a permanecer
en casa desde que las medidas entraron
en vigor hace una semana pero shanghai
no toma riesgos para contener el brote
las autoridades han construido este
centro de aislamiento improvisado con
capacidad para más de 40 mil camas todos
los que han dado positivo incluido los
pacientes asintomáticos deben
registrarse para llevar a cabo la
operación se han desplegado en el lugar
la ayuda de miles de profesionales
médicos de otras partes de china ya el
país y ha enviado equipos médicos en su
mayoría a hospitales temporales desde
otras provincias para ayudar a shanghai
el primer lote de trabajadores médicos y
recolectores de muestras de las
provincias de jiangxi zhejiang y anhui
ya he llegado a shanghai quien sin ti
está zanja mientras tanto la paciencia
se agota entre los residentes de la
ciudad ante las estrictas restricciones
que han provocado el pánico de la compra
de productos básicos así como una
escasez de repartidores para llevar
comida a las millones de personas que se
encuentran en sus casas